and I'm not seeing whether Jeff stum or
um Houston Gibson have joined us and if
you have looking and I didn't see them I
didn't see them either so if they're
online and they're under assume name go
ahead and speak up
please
uh on now all right exactly on time yeah
well welcome to Great race 101 this is
what rookies need to know to be
successful in the great race
and um just go ahead and flip to the
agenda if you would
Ken and we're going to start with just
welcoming and a little housekeeping um
and uh just want to introduce ourselves
we're Janet and Steve hkey we've been
great Racers since
1999 was our first Regional rally and uh
we've done quite a few since then and uh
we keep coming back for more for some
reason and uh we have uh been the rookie
coordinators for the past year and uh
really enjoyed getting to meet some of
our rookies and and to just kind of
share some of our experiences to make
your experience
better well and I'm Steve I'm the driver
Janet's the Navigator uh it works best
that way because I've tried navigating
and it was less than successful the uh
so you you'll learn you where your
skills lie uh but what we're trying to
do today is is give you a idea about
what you're going to be looking forward
to as you go it's really exciting I mean
I'm sure a lot of you are excited to be
in the race uh even if you're not
exactly sure what you're going to be
looking at it's got to be as far as I'm
concerned it's the coolest thing you can
do with an old car I mean you can take
an old car out to Pebble Beach and park
it on the lawn and if you spend enough
money on it you're going to get a trophy
you know this is entirely different you
know you and your teammate and your car
all have to perform it's challenging
it's it's an endurance event and and
we'll get into that later so let's let's
uh just continue on with the agenda
we're gonna have some announcements from
Jeff and uh Houston uh we'll talk about
how to prepare before you leave we're
going to talk about the roles of the
driver and the Navigator and uh what
we'll be doing when we arrive in
Owensboro for the start we'll talk about
what the day in the life of your great
race team is what what you can expect so
get an idea of uh so you're not drinking
from a fire hose when you get there
which you will be but at least you'll be
prepared for that fire hose um and we'll
give you some sample course instructions
we're going to go through those um you
know instruction by instruction so that
you're really comfortable with the idea
of of what that big fat packet of paper
is that they'll hand you every morning
and uh then we'll talk about some
special circumstances that you may
encounter or you may not and uh then
we'll have some opportunity to answer
some questions so um on to the next
slide yeah and the next
slide um okay so um Ken I want to give
you an opportunity to introduce yourself
as well so um just kind of the
housekeeping of uh how the zoom works
and and
uh yeah hi I'm Ken Spencer and this will
be my fourth great race on I'm a
navigator also and all I can say is it
it is such great fun and thank also the
People You Meet it's it's just it's and
you're going across real America and it
it is really really nice and uh I've
this is the second one I've uh helped
out with with Janet and Steve they do a
great job so we're in good hands I'm
just going to be behind the scenes and I
may mute your microphone or anything
like that like if we hear a dog barking
in the background or anything like that
but thank you welcome and
enjoy
okay oh it's my turn it is what am I
talking what is the great race oh I need
new gloves the great race uh is a Time
speed distance endurance rally you're
given the time and the speed but not the
distance so in order to get a good score
you need to stay on course and on time
and at your correct speed uh sounds easy
enough to do uh there are lots of things
that can get in your way and make that a
little harder than it needs to be but
the challenge is that your team needs to
be able to communicate back and forth uh
have a common uh language and
terminology that you can use for the
things that we'll be talking about later
and um have a car that's reliable uh
virtually any car can win the race uh
the team that uh has the best
preparation usually does well but not
always there are things that happen and
you have to have a mentality that's
flexible if things don't work out the
way you wanted them to there are ways to
fix it so what we intend to do here is
give you some ideas of how things go
when it's normal and what you can do if
it's
not okay and uh
go on to the next slide and I'd like to
introduce our director of great race
Jeff
stum
Audi go ahead and unmute yourself
Jeff he's
unmuted now he's muted
again there you are that right y
Steve and Janet thank you all for doing
this thanks to Ken for putting this
together if you uh have questions you
can do it and and Ken will take all that
and uh make this a very nice uh
presentation I'm just here to like you
to listen uh if if anything uh technical
comes up I'll be glad to answer it keep
in mind that when this is over you're
going to come up with more questions
we're here your mentors are here Steve
and and and Janet are here I'm here
Houston's here we're glad to answer any
of these uh uh questions or calls at at
any time my cell number is in the bottom
of my signature on my email you all
should have at least gotten at least one
email from me uh throughout the last
year uh so I just want to make it we
want to we're doing this so that you
have fun and that you you understand it
going in so you can Max imiz your fund
and uh to keep you from uh disrupting
anybody else that might be around you
that's really trying to do better not
everybody's trying to win $50,000 a lot
of people have realistic
expectations uh we actually more gear
the race to you that have the realistic
expectations you're out there to do as
best you can uh uh uh you know have a
good time and a lot of you I feel like
the crack cocaine dealer we give you a
little taste and then you're hooked
because a lot of you will come back this
for steveen Janet been on 25 years this
is actually be will be my 30th year uh
my first race was in
1994 so it's um and it goes by fast so
uh you know we're here for you anything
that you might need um I do want to I'm
sure this will come up but if you don't
don't have a
speedometer you need to get a
speedometer and you need to to let us
know we might find a used one uh we
might even if you have to buy a new one
um it's they're they're very expensive
but they have uh they hold their value
and uh I think to maximize what you want
to do even if you're just having fun
you're going to want to have a
speedometer so um I know a lot of you
will be in Michigan uh I I will actually
be in a Michigan in Michigan six days
from now I'll be arriving on Monday uh
Houston rid on Tuesday and I know a lot
of you will start piling in there on
Wednesday and definitely by
Thursday um it what a great opportunity
for you to number one have fun it's
going to be a lot of fun things from the
Packer improving grounds to the stall
Museum to the will St Clair Museum uh
Franken MTH Michigan uh just a lot of
great uh places to go things to see and
people to associate with and we're also
going to Rally some
and it's better that you come and figure
something out on the spring rally make
that mistake on the spring rally instead
of on day one of the great race there's
also trophy run the day before the great
race starts in
Owensboro uh which will also give you
some valuable seat time uh before the
race starts on that Saturday so uh I'mma
mute myself back um H Houston do you
have if you have any housekeeping items
uh chime in um I think he was at a
funeral today uh I'm here think if you
have any
housekeeping items uh Now's the Time I'm
GNA mute and I if anything uh technical
comes up I'll be here and be glad to
answer
yeah hey as he mentioned I'm Houston I'm
the coordinator so hopefully I've I've
probably talked to a lot of you guys
over the last couple months getting you
ready for the the big Grace anything you
need feel free to reach out to me direct
if I hadn't talked to you uh as far as
housekeeping probably the biggest thing
is just making sure that uh we have
either you've emailed to me or it's on
your profile uh you know the all your
photos and the insurance for your race
vehicle we want to make sure everybody's
got updated insurance on the vehicle
they're going to bring to compete in so
uh anything you need I'm Houston atg
greatrace.com so look forward to meeting
you guys all in
person okay and um just if if you do
have questions along the way um don't
unmute yourself and ask them out loud
you can you can type them in the chat
we'll see if we can kind of get to them
along the way but we will have a a
designated question and answer period at
the end so um we'll we'll see if we can
kind of keep an eye on the chat just in
case Cas um but U let's go ahead and
move on and talk about how to prepare
yourself in your car before you
leave so next slide um Steve and I have
competed in a number of different
Vehicles over the years and uh choosing
your car is something very significant
that you want to make sure that you've
got it adequately prepared so uh next
slide and Steve will talk about um those
specific
preparations well there's a picture of
the time wise right there I've got mine
handy here and we can uh uh talk about
it as she's opening up the case which
protects it because it's been all over
the country tougher than na everywhere
so this can I get it in
Focus put it nearer your face there you
go oh okay I can do that
no Lean Forward yeah well the picture on
the screen is the same yeah the trick
with this thing is that it has four
holes in the back this is what you uh
adjust to set your Factor every morning
you'll go out and do a speedometer
calibration run and it will tell you
you're trying to hold 50 and if the
speedometer says 50 and the time works
out on your sheet it's fine chances are
you're going to have to adjust it and
these things are adjustable down to a
fraction they're very accurate and the
reason that they are as expensive as
they are partially is because they're
tough as Nails they'll they'll take a
tremendous beating they're actually
quite heavy and U the adjustability of
it so you can you can get it precise um
the reason we talk about having a
speedometer like this is because the
speedometer that came with your car is
no damn good and uh we're talking like
on our 64 stud Baker the factory
speedometer which is a Stuart Warner uh
is about two miles an hour slow at 50
now for a factory speedometer that's
pretty good for great race that's crap
you're you're going to lose time all day
long with something like that so the you
don't you can use a factory speedometer
but you have to do mathematical
calculations all the way on your trip to
compensate for the loss and your
Navigator's already got plenty to do
without having to do that the time wise
just makes life so much easier and it
will make your you'll score better with
it the um what are we talking about next
tires I need glasses
um the we we expect that your cars will
be prepared as if they were going on a
long trip meaning that you're not going
to put 12-year-old tires on your car um
and you want to use a a tire that will
um last the roads are tough and we
normally put the pressures on the tires
up at least to maximum and some folks
might push it just a little bit harder
just to keep the tire from expanding and
Contracting and throwing your speeds off
but uh sometimes the the right the race
route can't help it the teams that go
out and prepare the course we could have
a construction crew come through after
the sweep truck or sweep car goes
through and we had that happen last year
we were driving along and all of a
sudden uh three inches of asphalt
disappeared under the car um and you
know we took a bump and it was on a time
section and the you know smart thing is
to slow down and make up the time but
there was a stop sign within sight for
anything to you know yeah well the uh
just to say that your car needs to be
able to take a hit and make sure that
maintenance items obviously you're going
to change the oil in the filters uh
grease up wheel bearings all of those
things need to be done and then try of
the car to make sure that everything's
okay especially if you're doing a tuneup
on it put some hours into the car before
you load it on the trailer and take it
to the race spare parts normally what I
bring in the car are the things that I
can change on the side of the road there
will be a sweep truck if your car breaks
and you can't fix it just keep it on the
race route get it out of the way of
traffic and a team will come and pick
you up and bring you back into the hotel
there's no reason to try to replace a
drive shaft on the side of the road
during the race uh although I've seen it
done and
um anything that you can replace
quickly carry with you um because when
you get back to the hotel there are
people who will chase down and help you
find the replacement part you need to
get you back on the road the next day
one of the coolest things about great
race is how much the other teams will
help folks get their car back on the
road the next day and uh they could beat
them uh in the competition but that's
not the part the point the point is that
everybody gets to go um the performance
chart are we going to talk about that
together we will talk about that later
so but you'll need to be testing your
car
and can't see it yeah all right it's in
the slides well well you need to know
how long it takes for your car to get up
to and to slow down from given speeds up
to 50 miles an hour you need to know
what your car will do because that's how
you calculate your timing and then the
decals will be sent in the mail I
understand from Houston that we're going
to have some of them I think for
Michigan hopefully that'd have to be in
the next couple of days um but
regardless the decals are required if
you have a show car there you don't like
to stick stuff on your car that will be
a problem uh the decals are required for
the sponsorships that help pay for the
race and uh yes time out if if you're if
you come to the spring rally if you any
team in the spring rally and we have 90
teams and the spring rally they're not
all in the great race but I would say 75
plus are in the Great race this summer
you will receive your set of decals for
the spring rally and you will receive
your set of decals for the great race if
you're not in the spring rally when we
get back from the spring rally we will
mail you or FedEx you your decals so if
if you're uh I don't even I don't know
if Bob Merck's coming to Spring Rally or
not I can't remember but if he is he is
well if he wasn't coming soon as soon as
soon as I get back I would mail him his
his deals if he wasn't coming and there
are be people in the spring race who are
using rental cars and uh other things
like that
and there will be a they will have a uh
spring rally door Cal to go on their
car that is different than the great
race door numbered decal okay so that
way you can take your you if you're in a
rental car good question Steve if you're
in a rental car you get your spring
rally decal you get your great race
decals you would put your spring rally
decal with your number and they all
should correspond with your great race
number but it's a different decal on
your car and you keep the rest of them
to go home to put on your regular race
car got it so it it's uh now if and I
know we have some Canadians on the call
today uh and we obviously have Japanese
Australian
British French everywhere else
participants that are that are generally
veterans we do not ship decals overseas
or to Canada because they just don't
seem to ever make it uh and we will we
bring those to our Adan friends and the
others uh at uh uh in Kentucky if if
they're not in the spring R thank you
for that Jeff okay let's move on to
talking about the roles of the driver
and Navigator and so we'll start with
driving
101 and uh Steve take it away okay so my
drivers out there you'll hear the joke
that drivers are stupid but the reason
for that is because the ability to hold
an exact speed on that speedometer is
hard uh it requires a the ability to
scan uh with your peripheral vision
what's going on around you you can't
focus 100% on the speedometer and you
can't focus 100% on the road you have to
be able to divide your attention between
the instrument and the highway that's
why when you get your speedometer you
want to mount it as high as you can so
it's in your field of vision as you're
looking out
um when you make your performance chart
and you find out how quickly your car
goes from 0 to 30 or 0 to 35 and how
quickly it goes from 35 to zero your
Navigator is using those numbers to
calculate uh when they can take you out
at a start we'll cover that later but
the trick is that you have to drive the
car the same way every time you don't
have to drive it wide open throttle to
make those numbers you just have to be
consistent with it so when you go out
and practice how long does it take me to
go from0 to 30 you are going to uh drive
it in such a way that your car can do
that um and do it the same way every
time I try to leave a little margin for
uh extra power in case I'm on a hill or
something like that and the uh the
speeds you know if particularly if you
have a car with like an Open Exhaust or
it's a little louder it's much easier to
hold your speed and rate of speed
increase by listening to what the car
sounds like uh you'll develop those
techniques on your own but it's
important at some point to go out and
find out just exactly what your car will
or will not do um the
um ah
Navigators um the driver
cannot compensate for what he thinks is
too slow or too fast that's the
Navigator's job uh if you've gone too
far at a higher speed and you have to
get back to the speed you're supposed to
be it's easiest if the driver can slow
down the same amount that they went
faster and hold that for as much time as
you think you were off that speed this
is the Precision Driving part of it uh
um the uh you can't guess that well I
think I'm going slower than 35 and I
need to speed up to like 37 don't do
that because if you do your Navigator's
got nothing to work with you're you're
just guessing and the Navigator can't
work with those numbers you just need to
be precise repeatable performance if
you're drag race fans back in the day
when we used to have ET brackets where
you can bring any car to the drag strip
you get your speed dialed in on
qualifying runs and then every time you
run in competition you're trying to get
as close to that same speed as you can
and the person who gets closest to that
speed wins the race it's kind of how
this works the um
uh oh visualize the course ahead this is
really important um it's something that
you learn in Aviation for one thing is
you want to be looking not at the
speedometer and not at the hood ornament
you want to be looking down the road
look you know when you can look farther
ahead see if there's a tractor pulling
out ahead of you or a school bus that
looks like it's going to stop and turn
its red lights on or there's a grain
truck that looks like it's going to pull
out of the field and start to pull over
you can make adjustments on your time
and your speed if you give your
Navigator enough time to react to it uh
so your Navigator is not looking down
the road like you are you know the
Navigator is looking at the uh the
charts and for the signs that you're
going to be making your turns and
Maneuvers on so when it comes to
something as a driver you look and say
gosh there's a train over there on the
left side I don't know if it's going to
cross here or not but let your Navigator
know we could have a problem so the
Navigator can figure out how to handle
that problem we'll cover that later
and um making sure that you're
physically
prepared I'm primarily talking about
hydration uh those of us who get older U
find that U during the course of the day
you can get a little foggy uh in your
brain operation uh and and uh I like to
use chewing gum they help me uh keep
things sharp uh hydrate as much as you
can realizing that you also have to deal
with the results of hydration at some
point you know we're going to give you
plenty of potty stops but uh that
becomes an issue too um and then but
make sure you're in good physical shape
as well um if you are basically
sedentary and and um you go into this
event there is a lot of of stress there
is a lot of lack of sleep um there is
all you know just you want to make sure
you're in the best physical shape that
you are so that you can uh you can
perform well be have Clarity of mind um
especially for the for The Navigators
that you be be able to focus because
you've got to be focusing basically for
10 hours straight you you just can't let
up so um just make sure you're in good
physical shape and if you need to start
hitting the gym between now and June do
it the average leg is about an hour and
a half so you need to be able to drive
in the car for an hour and a half uh one
of the things I do is I bring extra
glasses uh and leave them in the car if
you should break them or lose them or
leave them at a restaurant the last
thing you want to do is trying to squint
looking at the speedometer trying to so
anything uh drugs uh anything that you
need to have with you um that kind of
stuff just keep it in mind and be ready
for it okay let's talk about the
Navigator's
role um so um generally you've got a lot
of equipment that that you're dealing
with I have a lap board that you can see
a picture of it's got all of my stuff
it's got my performance chart on
it um well it's it's a real pretty
picture there on on the screen um so
it's got my clock it's got my
performance chart I've got my
uh stopwatch handy I've got it velcroed
to the uh to the lapboard so that I can
pick it up and put it down and not lose
it um most most Navigators just wear it
around their neck and so it's handy to
grab with your your hand anytime you
need it uh your time of day clock uh
recommend that you have one that has a
sweep
secondhand um and preferably the the the
second hand itself is very close to the
face of the clock so you're not seeing
any Parallax because you're relying on
those seconds and half seconds if you've
got one that is calibrated with with
markings for each individual second that
will be more accurate for you um I've
got uh little clips that have pens and
highlighters um you're going to have
your start order that they give you at
the end of each day for the following
day that will have the list of uh the
cars in what order they will go out so
you will know what your start time will
be and then of course you'll have your
um 30 to 50 pages of root instructions
so just make sure you've got a setup
that's comfortable for you that you can
see and that um your driver can see it
as well if they if there's any question
about you know what does that
intersection look like there there there
will be a visual diagram and and so if
I'm trying to describe well it's kind of
a five way and this goes to you know I
can just point to it with my pen and say
you're looking for this
so you've got all that at your at your
disposal okay so um then the next slide
on the root
instructions um you'll start with some
nice clean beautiful root instructions
they'll have real pretty pictures of
signs um you are the arrow so you will
start each root instruction you are the
dot at the arrow and it will show where
you procceed through the um through the
instructions so you can see that the
third one down you're making a right
turn the others you're just passing to
the left of something that is on your
right so you'll see there's a crossroad
sign there is a right curve sign there's
a a little squiggle sign uh so that's
that's how you root instructions start
out looking nice and nice and pristine
and then by the end of the day you've
marked them up and made all kinds of
notes to yourself and highlighted things
but we will go over that later on but
that that's basically what you're
working with as the Navigator
okay so communication this is the key
thing you're going to see a lot of these
kinds of signs on the road and when you
as the Navigator are talking to your
driver you need to be able to
communicate to them what they're looking
for so um that could be a right curve
warning sign or it could be a be right
or that you whatever it is you need to
be able to to know what your driver is
talking what what your Navigator is
telling the driver uh the next one you
could call that a hard left you could
call that a 90 degree left you could
call that a dead man left um but make
sure you're using the same words each
time um side road to the left um Double
Dead Man uh hard left chair any any um
any combination of things but make sure
you're you're using the same words and
understanding what that means the last
one could be called a snake it could be
called a squiggle it could be called a
multiple curved Road up ahead um and
there's actually two versions of that
that one is a left right left as opposed
to a right left right so just know that
you will see both and Janet
yes on that sign that the the squiggly
that starts to the left at the bottom
there are Squig that start to the right
at the bottom but
it is not our intention this came up
last year it is not our intention to
trick you if you see that sign and it's
in the other direction starting at the
bottom you still do the
maneuver it is it is not we do not this
is not a trick rally we not not a trap
rally uh this did come up last year
there was an instance where it went one
way and it in reality and we had it the
other way even though we did four course
runs we you know we did miss it
95% of the teams did it
correctly were two or three PE teams
that did not do it correctly and they
were very good teams because they were
looking for the correct sign we they
over the years we've kind of tried we've
we've we kind of outsmarted ourselves in
a way uh the intention is not to trick
anyone just wanted to clarify that okay
uh let's go on to some great race
etiquette Steve's going to tell us a
little bit about what to expect and and
how to make the best of
it so you're G to be out on the course
with a number of cars and a number of
people of varying skill levels there are
some people who take it very seriously
and they're looking for that big check
uh there are some folks that think that
it's just out here for fun theyve paid
their money and they're going to do it
in whatever way they think they'd like
to and they could get in the way of the
people who are trying to win um don't be
that person yeah what we're trying to do
here is is run your own race do what you
think you need to do to stay on course
and on time um however there might be
circumstances under which um
if you if if you're driving along at say
45 and everybody else is doing 50 you
might have done something wrong and you
might be in people's way the cars are
spaced at one minute apart so when
you're going slow the cars are closer
together when you're going fast you can
hardly see each other there's plenty of
room within that minute to maneuver back
and forth um the uh if
couple of things just to keep in mind if
you're doing something that's going to
make it harder for somebody else maybe
you shouldn't be doing that um and there
are occasions when some teams like to
start their day from a dead stop in the
middle of the road we don't recommend
that but you can't tell them not to do
that um it's uh some of the roads
there's no traffic and it it doesn't
really matter uh but in other cases
um there can be things where uh you're
lined up for a start at one of those
signs and you have five or six cars
waiting for their turn to leave if the
car in front doesn't have to leave for
like 10 minutes he's in everybody's way
behind him there's a lot of examples of
this these are minor issues but they're
just as a rookie you don't want to be
the guy that the other people complain
about during the day uh still run your
own own race still do the thing that
you're you think you need to do and if
it's becomes an issue uh during the race
you know come to us come to Jeff or any
of the other Racers particularly if they
have an e next to their name as expert
just ask them the question what do I
doing circumstances like that everybody
will help you out everybody's been a
rookie everybody's made mistakes
everybody has blocked somebody else on
the race course don't get mad at them uh
don't get mad with your teammate is let
it slide off and um uh just try to be a
a good citizen while still being
competitive I know that sounds difficult
but regardless um Spectators and fans
one of the things you'll find as you're
running along the road is that when you
get 120 130 cars passing a single point
one minute apart it's going to attract
Spectators there's plenty of time for
them to call their buddies on their
phone and they come out they set up lawn
chairs alongside the road they wave at
you and you can wave and be you can
smile you know and be polite um
sometimes when you're at a stop sign and
you're ticking down seconds before you
have to leave somebody will come up and
say hey where you guys going uh you
could wave your hand say hi sorry we're
busy and uh take off you don't want that
distraction during the race when you're
off the clock spend as much time as you
can talking to the folks that come out
and see the race they may want to do it
at some point um same with the Press uh
you know there I've had plenty of times
and uh reporters have come up to me in
these little towns that the local
newspaper wonder if they could ask some
questions um I'm happy to do that if
you're not the kind of person that wants
to do that you say you know I'm sorry
but you see that guy over there uh with
a studio Baker he can talk to you he can
answer your questions just be be polite
because the intensity of the competition
can get to you and you don't want to
snap at anybody or or or seem rude while
you're doing it Spectators could also
mess you up um one of the things that we
like about having Spectators along the
side of the road is that we know we're
on the right road yeah we call them
great race people and if there's people
on the side of the road waving at you
you smile and say yeah we're on the
right road yay lawn chair people lawn
chair people thank you if suddenly you
don't see anybody anymore more you might
have missed something uh so they can be
a help at that part uh they can also be
a distraction yeah I've had cases where
the people would be at the side of the
road at an intersection and say
everybody else went that way and your
Navigator is telling you to go this way
guess which one you're going to listen
to most of the time all of the time all
of the time um because you could be in a
maze and a maze is when the the course
Loops back on itself and at some point
the car is going to uh turn left or or
turn right at the very same intersection
so someone's trying to be helpful and
they're really not yeah but but you'll
figure that out as you go along um but
they can they can distract you from you
know if you're looking at a group of
people on the left that are shouting and
waving and the sign that you want is on
the right you could miss that sign and
get off course ask me how I know that um
we did that on the last day of
competition last year and it cost us
probably two places and maybe a couple
thousand dollars yep that it can happen
so um the the uh keep in mind where
you're supposed to be one minute apart
from your other cars be polite with the
other Racers and The Spectators along
the way and then when you get in at the
end of the night and you have a beer you
can talk about the jerk that pulled off
in front of you and cut you off all
right let's go ahead and talk about your
speedometer calibration
now the slide changes there there it is
it's yours is it okay it is um the timey
speedometer uses a magnetic pickup you
put two blue two magnets on the left
front wheel equidistant apart set up a
uh a probe so it's adjustable so you can
pick up the signal as the magnet goes by
and then you power the speedometer with
a 12vt power source some people like to
use separate batteries I like to put
mine into the uh electrical system of
the car itself uh that depends on your
car and how you like to do things like
that because I can tell you people who
uh Power their speedometers with a
separate battery so they don't have to
cut into the wiring system on their car
at some point they will forget to charge
it overnight and I've seen that happen
too uh the time
wise I'm going to try this and see if it
works let see if I can get it in focus
and well this is this is the rig I used
to mount the time wise on the uh on the
car the because it's a a 60s car it has
a small Mast uh for the steering and I'm
just using a regular uamp on that with a
piece of rubber on it to hold it in
place then on the other end I have a
large uh high gear style clamp that the
spedometer goes into and holds it in
place just focus you stupid me get it
back here somewhere anyway the idea is
that the way I have this design is so it
will stick up above the dashboard and
it's in my line of sight
uh without having to make any
modifications on the car itself yeah
it's the light reflection on it I think
but anyway you also need to be able to
take your speedometer out because at the
beginning of the day you're going to be
setting your uh factor and you're going
to have numbers I don't know if you can
read it on here or not but the sticker
on the back
says maybe here
if you guys you might turn off your blur
background and that might just did oh
perfect hey perfect now we're talking
you can see I've got a a sticker on the
back that says up that makes a big
difference because if it's upside down
and you turn those dials you're going to
be in real trouble and ask me how I know
that but you have to be able to take the
speedometer
itself out of the holder so that when
you're parked on the side of the road
you can take this out flip it around use
your little Jeweler screwdriver and when
the Navigator tells you what your factor
is you dial that into the back of the
speedometer so wherever you mount it you
have to be able to get to it also if you
forget uh like if you have the if it's
powered to the car and you turn the car
off before it stops rolling this needle
will be wherever you pull the plug on it
so when you restart your speedometer
will be off this face unscrews and you
can push that needle back to zero point
one of the things you want to check
before you take off is that the
speedometer is actually at zero before
you leave okay Hank mul has just given
us a really great suggestion in the uh
in the comments I remove the back plate
of the speedometer enlarge the holes to
the adjustments to make it easier to see
and calibrate that's a really good idea
I'm going to do that
I've been afraid to take that thing
apart thanks T it's a great idea okay so
speedometer adjustments go on to the
next
slide and this is what you'll be doing
during the race when you run the
speedometer calibration part of the uh
each day um you will find out whether
you are either early or late based on uh
the rally
Masters calibration so you run the when
you first get get there um they'll give
you a measured mile which is basically a
speedometer calibration run and uh it
might only be 10 or 15 minutes worth and
then you come back the opposite
direction it's always it's generally run
on an interstate you're running at 50
miles an hour and then you're just
looking to see what the uh the signs are
along the way and then you will have a a
totally lapsed time that you're trying
to match so um you have the opportunity
to adjust your speedometer as many times
as you need to to try to lock that in
until you do match um the factors the
the four numbers on the back if you're
running early you need to increase that
factor if you're running late you need
to decrease that factor so what you do
is you they give you the correct time
and you have your actual time you need
to convert that into total seconds so
total time uh of the correct time
divided by your actual time in seconds
time times the factor will give you the
new factor to plug into your uh
speedometer you can do that with a
calculator as long as you are not on the
race so when you when you set up your uh
your measured mile ahead of time when
you get to Owensboro you can use your
calculator for that to to just lock it
in but each day during the race you're
going to be doing that adjustment
manually so um once you have The Factor
locked in you take that number divid it
by 3600 and that gives you the number of
clicks for each second per hour that you
are either early or late in our case
it's
1.13 clicks per second so um I know that
I will have to um if I'm eight seconds
late I'm going to do nine clicks but
otherwise if I'm five seconds late I'm
going to do five clicks and so forth and
then you'll just
um convert your early or late time into
seconds multiply times that single click
factor and then you'll just do that
number of clicks on your speedometer
itself and just to add when you get the
speedometer you're going to be given a
instruction sheet which shows you how to
do the initial setup you'll Mark a spot
on with your tire on the ground and
you'll give the wheel a complete
Revolution all the way around measure
the distance that it's traveled and
that's your initial setup on this so
it's very much set to the size of your
tire uh and if you have to replace the
tire during the race you'll obviously
need to recalibrate this um secondly
because these holes are small and Hank
mole makes a really a good suggestion I
keep a small flashlight in the center
console of the car so that I can
illuminate the wheel on the inside you
can can't even see it this way but it's
white has seven clicks on it I believe
10 through zero okay well fine that's
not my
job and um I have a small flashlight
that I keep with the Jeweler screwdriver
to make that adjustment so I can see
inside and make sure that I have it
exactly right one click off and your
your your next leg is is not
good all right let's go on to the next
we want to make sure that we have enough
time to go through the instruction
instuctions and U take your questions at
the end so hey Janet could I say one
more thing on the speedometers to the r
yes oh my suggestion to you is unplug
your speedometer when you're going five
miles an
hour and then you'll find out because
everybody freaks out and goes how do I
fix this all you got to do unscrew the
the bezel long- winded thing take it off
with your finger turn the speedometer
dial clockwise up to the top again
that's all there is to it it's not that
hard thank you thanks Bob all right
let's go on creating a performance chart
this is something that you're going to
be relying on very heavily um so what we
recommend just the basics you just need
to know the basics of how long how many
seconds you lose for accelerating
decelerating and turning
at each speed between basically 15 and
50 miles an hour so we recommend you
find a straight level section of Road
about a half mile long if you can do a
full mile um that's even better um
preferably with little or no traffic and
uh you'll need to be able to turn around
safely at the uh each end of the course
and also have enough time to accelerate
up to 50 mil an hour before this the
start of your course so again you're
going to be doing that at different
speeds making frequent stops um so you
want something that takes about 40
seconds to um to Traverse at 50 mil an
hour and you'll just Mark each end of
the course with a marker like an orange
traffic cone or a stick with a flag on
it um and if you're running the lower
speeds you can do a much shorter run
just to save time because you really
don't want to be out there for a minute
and a half it's the longest minute and a
half of your life um going 10 miles an
hour
um and then you'll run that course
entering at those various speeds 15 20
25 30 35 40 45 and 50 over and over and
over and over um you want to do at least
four runs at each speed record the times
um so that's entering at that speed
maintaining that speed through the
course and then
um exiting at that speed so that becomes
your base so um you kind of average the
the four or five runs that you've done
so you know what your your base length
of time to go through that uh that
course is then you're going to
um determine how to ex uh get your
acceleration loss your deceleration loss
and your turn loss so we'll go to the
next screen for
that and yes um Bram you should
calibrate your speedometer as close as
you can before you do the performance
chart because that's just going to make
make it as accurate as possible so now
that you've got your base numbers you
start from a stop at the start line and
then you accelerate up to that speed and
finish at that speed through the course
so again do this four or five times and
um you know hit your um hit your
stopwatch when you get to the end and
you you should see a fairly consistent
number um for that acceleration loss
when you compare it to your time and so
that will give you your acceleration
loss can I jump in for a second for
those of you who are going to be using
riddle cars in Michigan same process it
doesn't have to be a specific distance
between your two points just get out
there with your factory speedometer
which is probably on a modern car it's
probably electronic and it's probably
fairly accurate and get out there and
see if holding 50 between your two
points uh actually comes out correct on
your time what's the well the laps time
at 50 you would only know that after
practicing it a coule for exact mile but
they're not going to measure out of
miles to do no no don't need it's not
important all you need to do is
establish something that is at 50 or 30
or whatever it is find out that time
then find out how long it takes you to
stop at a complete stop then go again
but you use the same procedure if you
have a TimeWise or if you're using the
factory speedometer in the
car okay so now you've got your
acceleration loss your next one that
you're going to do is a oh go back go
back um the next one you're going to do
is a stop and go so you're entering the
course at speed so back back one more
yeah stay there um start start through
at speed and then you do an immediate
stop and immediate um acceleration back
to speed and if you can do that two or
three times within your course then you
you'll be able to average out the loss
so say you had three stop and goes
within that course then um you could
just compare that to your
base and the difference say the
difference was 15 seconds then you
divide that by the number of stop and
goes you did which is three so now you
know that your loss at that speed is 5
Seconds for a stop and go
you already know what your acceleration
loss was so you subtract your
acceleration loss from your stop and go
and now you have your deceleration loss
so you've kind of done two at once that
way um now the
um procedure for doing turns we
recommend that as you're trying to do
consistent driving skills for the
drivers that every every time you do a
turn that you break and uh get down to a
speed of 15 miles an hour at the turn
and then accelerate out to your outspeed
so if every turn you make you slow down
to 15 and then accelerate it's going to
be a consistent number for you as far as
your time loss that will help your
Navigator so in in working on your
performance chart you enter at speed and
then when your Navigator tells you break
down to 15 miles an hour and then back
up to the
speed and same thing if you can do it
three or four times during your um
during your course then that that will
just help you to finish your process a
little bit more quickly so again the
um sorry thank you oh I'm reading the
notes in the
margin so again if you've made like
three or four runs you just um divide by
the number of um the the loss of each
speed and just for driver technique when
I do a stop and go when I stop the car I
wait until the car rocks
back that when you're stopped because if
you're just coming down to three or four
miles an hour and you hit it again
that's not a consistent measurement but
if you wait till the car stops and rocks
then you're stopped so there's a really
good question in the margin and this is
probably not a rookie level answer um I
actually have on my chart it's an ex
Excel spreadsheet and it shows the
percentage
of difference between each of the
speeds
um so I I have one one set factor for a
30 to 30 and a 40 to 40 and a 35 to 35
and then the 30 to 50 is a certain
percentage of that and so it's a it's a
mathematical calculation um let's let's
just that's hard let's just get to just
go down to 15 and then correct 3 seconds
you guys are rookies and rookies are
your goal is to finish within your
minute um Seconds come later but if you
can finish within your minute close as
you can you're going to score well and
that's how you start this deal the
advanced stuff goes to the point where
uh everybody has their own way of doing
these fractions of seconds that's not
your concern your concern is staying on
course and staying in your minute
concentrate on that and these techniques
will get you through that just fine and
so you can see when we started out we
had a performance chart that looked like
the chart on the left we now have a
performance chart that after 25 years
that looks like the chart on the right
you are fine with the chart on the left
you will do great we W rookie with that
chart on the left so you can do that too
all right let's let's go on to the next
one support
Cruise there we go um support crews are
awesome um not every team has the
privilege or joy of having a support
crew um we've probably again over the 25
years we've had a support crew maybe six
or seven of those years and uh otherwise
we are kind of doing it all on our own
it makes a huge difference if you have
family friends um you know car club
members that want to experience the
great race people that think oh great
race would be something fun to do maybe
but I'd like to find out more about it
well how would you like to be our
support crew and then they'll get hooked
right
Julie so uh you don't need a support
crew for the Michigan race you'll be
coming back to the same Hotel each night
and it's really helpful when you're
traveling halfway AC all the way across
the continent like we did last year and
then having we'll be doing again this
year and doing again this year uh we
will having a team that can take your
truck and trailer and haul your uh
luggage luggage and check you in at the
hotel and do stuff like that is great
when you're at the end of the day and
you're tired um but it's not necessary
if you're going to a regional rally
which is one of the big pluses of doing
that and secondly you know if you have a
big enough car and you have two guys
that are you not carrying a lot of
luggage and stuff like that and you know
how much Geer you bring with you uh for
tools like Jacks and things like that
that you may need overnight to fix
something uh the support crew can be
really helpful the support Crews have
their own set of instructions for
getting from this day to the next day um
which are signed and they're not on the
race course at any time in fact you can
have be disqualified if your support
crew is on the race route when you're on
a Time section um so that's something
that let your potential support crew
guys know that you'll be able to go
around and look at anything you want
stop at other places sometimes they have
organized venues for you to go to take a
leisurely lunch while your team is out
working their butts off out in the field
somewhere but
a support crew if you can get one is
really
helpful okay uh next one what to
pack next okay so um expect all kinds of
weather we have rallied in brutally hot
off this
thermometer uh heat we have had rain um
there will be hot and humid there will
be thunderstorms there will be
um snow snow we had snow uh and you know
if you're in an open Speedster you're
just going to have to have a full-on
rain suit and you're going to have
something plastic to cover your root
instructions with so that um they don't
get so wet um had a hurricane once uh
yeah so so just be prepared for anything
pack accordingly um again if you're in
an open car you'll need sun protection
so pack lots of of quality Sun screen um
great race does give you a hat you may
need a little bit more than that um make
sure you've got drinking water in a
cooler inside your car and replenish it
each day uh as I mentioned before uh
Navigator may want to take pictures
you're not going to have access to your
cell phone so get a digital camera you
can you can pick up a cheap one at Best
Buy or or Walmart or wherever um but
make sure that you've um you've got the
ability to to take pictures during the
day you're going to want to have those
memories um great race will be selling
you merchandise um they will provide
each driver Navigator with an event
t-shirt and a hat they'll have other
shirts you will love their other shirts
they're so cool so um pack fewer shirts
than you think you'll need and and
sometimes we've even had some of our
overnight stops and lunch stops give us
shirts they give us goodie bags with
free stuff so um pack pack fewer than
what you need um again if you have a
support crew and they're willing to do
your laundry and you're willing to let
them do your laundry you can pack fewer
things as well um one creative team has
suggested that you buy cheap underwear
and throw them away each night okay um
we have seen a team bring one set of
clothes and wash them in the hotel sink
every night um that was also the team
that was changing out their um drive
shaft during on the side of the road
because they filled their car with all
the extra parts instead of
luggage don't be that team uh there are
lots of stops at gas stations
um with mini Mars if you need to pick up
Essentials you'll see lots of Walmarts
and auto part stores all along the way
um okay now I have a question here uh is
a GoPro camera allowed because you
generally will run that GoPro camera
with your phone I'm guessing probably
not and I'm G to ask jeffre Houston to
to uh weigh in on that
one uh Yes actually GoPro cameras are
allowed and
encouraged uh great
uh if if if your phone is not in the car
GoPro cameras uh in fact the the best
video we ever got was Scott Henderson
saving that team from going over the
cliff at at uh Mount Washington um with
his GoPros were mounted on his car so
you're you're absolutely fine with u a
GoPro as long as you're not using any of
that I don't even know I didn't even
know about how it works with a phone
long as you're not using your phone to
just set it
app and you turn it on and off with your
phone but the phone doesn't have to be
in the car for the GoPro to
work in the car meaning it can be in the
trunk and not yeah yeah and and just
turn it on let it
run no great thanks for that
clarification okay and again under what
to pack car parts only what you can fix
or replace on the side of the road um
and basic hand tools if there's anything
that you need a special tool for you
know like the haze uh where you may need
a special tool to adjust the points or
something like that make sure you have
those tools because you're not picking
those up at Napa uh but otherwise lots
of people have bought tools you'll have
time after the end of the day on your
way to the hotel to stop by an auto part
store or during the race itself they put
in breaks there's a lunch break there's
potty braks there's gas breaks sometimes
you can pick up stuff in the gas station
uh sometimes you have enough time on
your lunch break to stop by uh an auto
part store to pick up some coolant or
extra oil or something like that so it
while the time is limited it's not uh
it's not finite I mean you can you'll be
able to uh get what you need pretty
quickly unless you need tires tires are
a problem because when you get in at the
end of the day the tire stores are all
closed and they don't open early enough
for you to go and get tires before the
race starts and we have stories about
that but we'll save that for another
time because we need to move on so when
you arrive in
Owensboro um go ahead to the next
slide um so Wednesday uh teams will
arrive there may be some host Town
special events um it's a great
opportunity to meet with your U Mentor
team teams um and if you're a mentor to
meet up with your rookies um Thursday
will be registration and vehicle
inspection Jeff just sent out the
schedule so that you know um what time
you are expected to um to be at the
registration area and to get your um
your Tech inspection done and uh then
again you'll have the opportunity to
pick up your T-shirt and hat and
purchase additional
merchandise they'll give you your
measured mile for the speedometer
calibration and and uh you can just kind
of go hang out in the parking lot check
out everybody else's cars and um
introduce yourselves yeah you know the
rookies get to know each other uh that
what we did we had a rookie class the
year that we started in the big race in
2000 and uh we stayed friends up until
you know over the years people had you
know dropped out but you have a special
bond with the other rookies that started
out the same time you
did um stepen Janet uh I get asked uh
regularly and we will the actual
schedule of events for the great race
will come out this Thursday in the
newsletter oh great but awesome just if
you can you should arrive in Owensboro
on
Wednesday the opening reception will be
that evening at Green River distillery
in Owensboro it's a neat place and then
Thursday is very active with
registration taking inspection just to
be clear the time you were given is the
time that you arrive at
registration you go through registration
it should only take 10 minutes or so you
might want to spend 10 minutes buying
some souvenirs and then you will
immediately take your car outside of the
registration area at the convention
center to the parking lot it'll be very
obvious where it is where all the great
race tents are set up for Tech
inspection so a lot of a lot of rookies
always ask me oh uh is that my time for
registration or Tech both it's your time
to go to registration that time if you
were if you're
11:04 a.m. that means you should be in
the registration room at 11:4 a.m. 11:04
a.m. go through that immediately take
your car and go through Tech inspection
right after if you do everything
correctly if your paperwork is all done
and I say paperwork it's all electronic
now if that is all completed they'll
push you in and out of registration
pretty quick get you out to Tech
inspection and then you can be on your
way doing all the other things like the
measured mile getting your speedometer
dialed in and things like that uh the
people of Owensboro also throwing a
barbecue on that Thursday from 11:30 to
2:30 it's going to be a lot of fun to a
good Southern uh barbecue where they
actually cook the barbecue in 55 gallon
drums where they cut them in half and
make their own make their own barue
things it's a very popular thing in the
South so uh you want to arrive if you
can by uh you know Endo wboro by
Wednesday uh
afternoon got it thank you Jeff all
right then let's go on to a day in the
life of a great race
team so before your day
starts um you will know your race start
time the previous day uh it will be on
instructions um at the end of the
instructions for the day so you'll know
the race start time is you'll know what
your starting position is because they
will give you that order of start that
will list uh it have the race start time
it'll tell you what uh what position
you're going to be in who you're going
to be following and then uh you will
also know uh from the previous days
instruction what hotel you'll be picking
up your instructions from it will not
always be the hotel you are staying
staying at so you will need to know on
the previous day how to get to that
hotel that you're picking up the
instructions from in the morning and
what time to be there um so you'll
determine what your start time is you'll
have breakfast and you kind of work all
this backwards it's like I know I need
to be at this hotel at this time so this
is when we're going to have breakfast
this is when we're going to meet our
support crew to hand off our luggage or
you know pack it in the car um this is
when we're going to uh you can set your
clock and stopwatch in your hotel room
but you're going to want to recheck it
when you get to um where they hand out
the instructions and um pick up your
cour instructions 30 minutes before your
start time and um the important thing is
you know they they do the best that they
can to make sure that the instructions
are absolutely accurate but they will
have a team that will go through the day
before and also one very early that
morning that will determine if there is
any emergency
construction that's going on any road
closures any flooding anything that
makes the the route unsafe and they will
um give you emergency instructions
they'll be taped on the window of the
car where the uh where the clock is and
they will also be handed out to you at
registration but you want to make sure
that you pick those up and and um make
sure that you've looked through them and
made those adjust adjustments in your
course instructions and then you'll
start marking them up and um then you'll
be on your way so that's before your day
starts now the next
section next
slide on the road go ahead there
oh the race gives you a uh Speedo
calibration run every morning uh do not
assume that your factor from the
previous day even if you won the
previous day is going to be the same the
next day so you will have your Navigator
will have her course instructions which
will give you a route that you'll run at
exactly 50 miles an hour unless
otherwise told signs along the side
click the stopwatch see if your lapse
times are close or the same or determine
if you need an adjustment that's going
to happen every day and you need to do
it every day the um uh check your order
of start as a driver you want to know
the cars that are supposed to be in
front of you and behind you on that day
going to change every day so you want to
know that the car too ahead of you the
black Ford Roadster that's too ahead of
you has an e next to their name so they
are experts so you can get a pretty good
idea as a rookie when you're supposed to
be lined up for the start because that
guy's exactly two minutes ahead of you
um and then that through the course of
the day unless somebody gets off course
uh you're going to be holding that
position with those cars for the rest of
the day next day it changes um the
um let uh checkpoints is time to do
checkpoints um briefly very briefly your
score is determined by how accurately
you reproduce the time that it took from
the start to the checkpoint that is
controlled by the rally Master you don't
know what that is so when you see a
checkpoint coming up there'll be a green
sign on the side of the road you usually
can see it as the driver before the
Navigator will figure it out you tell
your Navigator checkpoints coming up so
she can make the stopwatch but you want
to hold your speed uh and make sure that
the speed that you're supposed to be at
at the next section is what you're like
if you think you're running late you're
trying to make up time you cross that
checkpoint you got to get back to the
speed that you're supposed to be because
that's the immediate start of the next
section you don't do anything else you
don't stop you don't talk to the
checkpoint workers you don't ask them
any questions you just drive right
through it like it's not there uh what
you will hear is them going and that's
for the Navigator so she can mark down
the time that's when you get your Cal
your stopwatch out and you look at the
time of day and you write that down in
the margin on your root instruction
you're going to do that a couple of
times before you get to lunch depending
on on the course uh lunchtime they give
you enough time to have
a decent lunch I wouldn't say it's
leisurely uh but you don't have to wol
it down and try to get out to the
restart and be there 30 minutes ahead of
when you're supposed to be there you
follow the instructions uh sometimes
there's not enough room for everybody to
be out there and you want to make sure
that you get something to eat and drink
use it back
and all that stuff they give you plenty
of time for that so you don't have to
rush it same thing when you're on the
road uh uh supposedly you filled your
car up with gas before you left that
morning if you didn't you know you're
going to have to figure out when and
where you can fill up during the race
sometimes they will tell you get gas
here because the next stops 120 miles or
whatever it is all cars are different in
terms of their fuel capacity and range
you have to know your car and what you
can get done um at the end of the day
when you get to your final checkpoint
and you can you can relax it'll be a
Transit from your final checkpoint to
where the race ends there will be a
formal gate that you'll go through
sometimes you get one for lunch but you
always get one at the end and you can
see the gate in the picture uh in the
slide where uh you will be given your
score by John and then they will park
your car and you will be in what's
called called it park for May for an
hour and a half or however much time
they've determined that you're going to
be there that's important you can't go
to the hotel you can't go to the tire
store unless you have permission from
the race director to be able to do that
because they have sold that City that
they were going to have 130 cars on
display for an hour and a half and you
need to be a part of that you can't
leave until the time is up and you'll
know because everybody will fire up
engines it'll be like the nd500 and
everybody's heading for the hotel
sometimes you can get dinner uh while
you're uh waiting during the show it's
great to talk to the people who come out
and see you I had a car just like this
except it was a Chevy and it was yellow
and uh all the stories that you'll get
which is a lot of the fun and then
sometimes dinner will be hosted and the
city will tell you where to go to find
your hosted dinner um that that can vary
day to day but that's kind of the way it
works you have your morning where you're
getting everything ready you got your
Speedo calibration run you run a couple
of legs on time you have a lunch break
you run a leg have a potty stop run a
leg or two and then get to the finish
and your score doesn't count till you
get across the Finish Line at the end so
you're actually at the end of the day
you're not really done you're just done
for that day you still have a time that
you have to start the next morning and
like Janet said you back up the clock
and say okay if I have to be here at
7:30 how far is that hotel from where
we're staying did I put gas in the car
do I need to have that ready do I need
to meet with my checkpoint or my support
crew uh and so for the every day of the
race your time is set you you know where
you're going to be and where you're
supposed to be
there all right let's go ahead and go
through some sample horse instructions
but first we're going to talk about the
four s's for
success I see what you did there
yeah okay over the years uh people who
have been doing this have come up with
uh a little acronym for how to
prioritize the things that you need to
do this kind of comes out of Aviation
where aviate navigate and communicate in
that order are something you're taught
when you first taught how to fly so that
you keep your brain focused on what you
need to do this is the most important
thing for rookies to keep in mind
throughout their race and Veterans well
yeah veterans sometimes forget yeah
Safety
First you can get the bit in your teeth
you can get excited you can get U
flustered you can get
um the adrenaline pumped up up and
sometimes you'll do things that you
wouldn't normally do on the road when we
were younger we made a lot of great
stories in great race and we'll tell
them to you over a beer sometime this is
not the time um but we would not do
those now no because you keep in the
back of your mind that as rookies you've
got throwout legs so you you know if you
end up being stopped by a train and then
there's another train and then there's
another train you know
okay what the hell we'll just throw that
one out and we'll get to the next one
and and make a start um or you're not
you see three school buses coming up on
your left while you need to pull out for
your start you make two de one of two
decisions one I can pull out early and
let my navigator figure out how to bleed
off those seconds or I can just wait
until they go by and we'll know how late
we are and then we can you know we can
file a time delay because we couldn't
pull out in front the school buses same
things happens if the school buses have
their little red lights on you're not
going to go and pass the school bus
while the red lights are on the rules of
great race state that you must obey all
traffic laws that includes speeding uh
it also includes U you know running stop
signs or running you know traffic
signals it's not worth it uh you can
figure out how to fix anything like that
and stay safe and still be
competitive um starting on
time single most important thing for
rookie to learn when do I go because
there is nobody on the course telling
you that like a checkered flag or green
flag say okay go now uh you're figuring
that out on your own it's going to be
based on your performance chart which
tells you how long it takes to get from
zero to 30 whatever your outspeed is and
your Navigator is going to give you a
count down for when you should take off
it will always be sooner than the actual
time that you your start begins because
you have to compensate for the time it
takes to accelerate to that speed um the
uh so if your clock is calculated you've
done your your performance chart your
speedometer is pretty close or about
right that'll work every time some
people will start from a dead stop which
is what we normally do some people will
always do it on a rolling start where
they come whipping past turn around come
back figure out how long that took and
the car that's supposed to be in front
of you may be somebody doing a flying
start when you do a flying
start um this is great for low
horsepower cars that need to get up to
speed especially if there's a hill ahead
um the uh Mark yes it is frowned on yeah
well the the idea being that you know
how early you are or how late you are
when you cross the Sun and you can make
those adjustments later but your car is
up to speed and you're not dependent on
if you got your the gear selection right
or horsepower or something like that um
staying on course
is as well as starting on time staying
on course is the most important thing
for everybody particularly rookies
because if you get off course figuring
out how to to fix the time you've lost
uh makes it more difficult uh sometimes
staying on court the the root
instructions are not designed to fool
you or trick you or anything like that
the street signs will be legible uh
they'll tell you which side of the
street the sign is on or if it's not a
sign you know if it's the second paved
road to the right that doesn't happen
often but sometimes it does uh you just
both of you need to have your heads up
looking for that now as a driver if you
have to slow down to make sure that
that's the right intersection that's
okay if it's not right speed up go a
little bit faster to make up for the
time that you lost and go back but don't
lock up all four wheels and and crank it
over like oh my God I have to make this
turn right now uh that doesn't usually
work very well but staying on course
even if you have to slow down a little
bit to make sure you make the right turn
that makes sense and then staying on
time clearly if you start on time and
you do all the correct speeds and you
stay reasonably on the course and your
Maneuvers are reasonably close you're
gonna have a good day uh so just keep in
mind that you you're constantly running
slower than the course is telling you to
run and you have to make up time you
know every time you slow down or stop or
anything like that but uh usually you
can staying within your minute is very
doable for rookies
hey Steve
yes um I want to jump in here and give
the dirty little secret about the great
race for all the rookies this is the
most important thing I think that's said
here
tonight and this is especially for my
friend Peter hery who has owned this
call who's been a great racer for since
the many years yeah huh many years oh 20
plus years but this will be
his first time to really navigate in the
entire gra great
race the instructions we give you if you
follow the instructions if you start on
time stay on course and follow the
instructions 90 to 95% of everything we
give you is free it's given to you if we
say go 40 miles an hour and you can go
40 miles an hour and it matches our 40
miles an hour which is easy all that is
free it's given to you there's a lot of
free time too just getting to the
certain start time so now we're down to
only 5 to
10% of the entire race is actually
handling turns stop signs the occasional
tractor what have you so if you can
start on time stay on time and follow
the instructions Drive the speed we tell
you to
drive right there youve you've mastered
90 to 95% of the entire great
race exactly right
all right let's look at some course
instructions so we can get an idea of
what you're going to be looking at each
day so the root instructions will be in
three sections there'll be a tire warm
up that'll just help you uh to to warm
up uh and you'll you'll see uh in the
column B that's the section that you're
on so you see the tire warm up that's
telling you that uh you're you're going
to be warming up your tires for however
many miles and for how many minutes and
then uh there will be a speedometer
calibration you see that down at the
bottom of the page you see that picture
of that uh analog
speedometer and um then that will be uh
where the next section uh and then
following the uh spedometer calibration
will be sequential timed instructions
and then there's four columns the First
Column will show you the description of
the road the signage the intersections
that you're going to be going through um
column B again it's what section you're
in column C is what speed and timing
you're going to be dealing with and then
column D don't ignore colum D there's a
lot of special instructions course notes
that are very helpful to you and then
the other number one thing that you need
to do when you pick up your root
instructions do not leave the table
until you go through that entire thing
it says it's 13 pages in there you make
sure that all 13 pages are there and in
the right order it's you know you're
dealing with a A you know a kink go or
or whoever that that made that and
sometimes the machines slip a little bit
so you want to make sure that that is
completely correct all right let's go to
the next
slide this is the spomer calibration
started on the previous page and it told
you what um what sign it was a speed
limit 65 sign at that speed limit 65
sign you're just going to hit your your
uh stopwatch and you're going to be at
the speed that it told you to be at
which uh was 50 mil an
hour so uh it's it's telling you that
you're going to be uh doing this for 24
miles and you're going to be um and it's
going to take you 25 or 20
minutes 25 minutes to to do that all
right so now we'll go on to the next
page um you are again you're the dot
with the arrows showing you the
direction that you're going to be going
through and so so the first thing you're
going to see is a sign on the right that
will say um Can buunk Port uh and so uh
in the third column you'll see that the
interval from where you started should
be 4 minutes 3.4 seconds and your total
elapsed cumulative time is the same
because you've just been to one sign so
far and so that should correspond to
your stopwatch but write down in that
right column what time you have on your
stopwatch now you're starting to look
for the next sign which you can see is
in another 3 minutes and 16 seconds
notice the arrow is now on the right the
sign is on the left so you got to orient
yourself to whatever you see there you
know that you're going to be seeing
looking for a sign on your left in three
minutes again just hit the split time on
your stopwatch don't hit stop and start
you're going to ruin everything so hit
the split time write down your split
time go on for another minute and 10
seconds there will be another sign on
your left then there will be another
sign on your right you just continue to
hit that split and and write it down uh
now you've got one where you're going
underneath a sign so obviously this sign
is overhead so it'll be on a bridge um
or it'll be on a a sign that's hanging
over the top um and just continue to um
to just ch uh tick those off as as you
pass them and what you're looking for um
as you're writing down those times is to
see if there's a steady progression of
being early or late so I'm looking at
those and I'm I'm comparing um say on
the second one I was at 7 minutes 17
seconds then okay I'm already two
seconds early at seven minutes and let's
go on down to the University of New
England that's at 12 minutes 55 seconds
if I'm at 12 minutes and 42 seconds then
I know I'm already 30 13 seconds early
so um you're you're watching for a
linear uh difference in being early or
late and then um you're going
to be able to um calibrate your
speedometer or know how to to make
changes throughout the day based on that
um if for some reason you uh hit the
stop instead of the split on your
stopwatch you can always restart at the
next sign you're just going to have to
do some math to change those elapse
times um sometimes there's traffic and
then you just you can't hold 50 miles an
hour um and again you you do the best
you can with what you're
given um generally speaking what happens
at 50 miles an hour is all the traffic
pulls away from you so you stay in the
right lane do your 50 miles an hour
people will honk at you sometimes that's
friendly sometimes it's not and uh just
motor along at 50 and the driver should
keep their eye out in case that lane
goes away so you'll have plenty of time
to transition into the next Lane to the
left and hold to
50 and uh to to Ken's uh Point don't let
the driver know oh we're running early
oh we're running L late because then the
driver will just mentally try to make up
for that you want the driver to be
holding the indicated 50 miles an hour
so that you will know exactly how much
correction that you'll need to make at
the end and yes the Arrow does represent
the car's position in reference to the
sign okay um so continuing on to the
next slide with the overhead so um
notice where it says there stay on I95
that might be an indication that there's
um possibly a
uh an intersection with another freeway
coming up and so sometimes when he does
that um
overhead sign that is to indicate what
Lane you should be in if that sign is
not directly overhead you were in the
wrong
lane okay um and then it will also give
you an idea of where um where you're
going to be exiting so pain Road 1 half
mile that's telling you that that exit
45 is pain Road that's where your the
end of your calibration is you see the
um uh sand uh what do you call those
things hourglass hourglass thank
you and so you see we are now starting a
Transit again that's the section of the
root instructions that we're in we're
starting a Transit and so that has ended
the calibration uh speedometer
calibration section you have a total um
that you're going to compare your elapse
time to their elapse time so that you
know that in 26 minutes are you 3
seconds early are you 10 seconds late
and then that will inform what you're
going to do to um to make that
correction and we'll talk about that a
little bit later all right so now you're
in a Transit you're just following the
instructions um and if you are going to
be making an actual change to your
speedometer don't do that right away
because you might miss the instructions
on where to turn and and uh make sure
that you're in a safe place and stopped
like a gas station or parking lot or for
your start and that's when you adjust
your
speedometer um if you can't if you're
using a rental car you won't be able to
adjust your speedometer you'll just be
know based on that time how many seconds
you need to correct at what time how
often throughout the day if you were uh
five seconds late in in 25 minutes then
you're going to be one second late every
five minutes so you'll correct one
second every five minutes or two seconds
every 10 minutes something like that
okay all right so now we're continuing
on let's go on to the next oh this is a
uh a no host uh lunch here so um that
just kind of lets you know what what's
available to you and you've got that uh
number in parentheses that 10 minutes
that lets you know that at that point
you are 10 minutes away from your
restart or from for your initial start
for the day and then it'll take you on
down you're going to be making a left
turn at a signal and now you are 8
minutes away from your start so let's go
on to the next
slide and this is the scary one you see
that digital clock and that is your
start so you're just following the
instructions to get to a stop ahead sign
which seems like a curious place to
start at a stop ahead but that is what
you'll be doing and you will know what
your start time is based on your root
instructions and your order of start so
um if you're looking at your rout
instructions and you are car 32 and that
is starting at 1:40 you would add 32
minutes to that and you would be
starting
at
212 and I'm not reading the the one
that's uh in there in the instructions
because it's too small yeah um but
basically you're adding your start order
to the time that's shown in that clock
and that is the the time of day that you
will be starting at so car number one
does does not start at 140 car number
one starts at 141 car number two at 142
car number 10 at 150 Etc and you will be
going to 20 miles an hour at that stop
ahead
sign so you know exactly what speed
you're going to be starting out at and
you're going to be looking at that order
of start to say okay we are now three
minutes before our start the car three
in front of us is starting now the car 2
in front of us
that's a Packard okay he's right there
he's in line um the car after that is a
32 Ford okay they're right in front of
us and the car that's behind us is
should be a pricer oh and there he is
okay so you know you're in the right
place by looking at that order of start
so that you can verify that you're where
you need to be at the time you need to
be all right so now you're just going to
start following those instructions one
by one by one by one
and if you see an instruction that says
zero miles per hour that will correspond
to a stop so obviously we're starting at
a stop ahead sign so you can expect your
next instruction is going to be a stop
so you're going to be going from 20
miles an hour down to zero for that stop
and then after you stop you're going to
be going to 30 30 miles an hour 35 um
35 and um it gives you 15 minutes 15
minutes 15 seconds for each stop however
remember you lose time when you
decelerate and you lose time when you
accelerate and so you're going to take
those numbers that you've already
created on that performance chart and
you're going to adjust that 15 seconds
accordingly so in this particular case
he's at 10.2 that means he loses a total
of 4.8 seconds in decelerating and
accelerating so you're going to hold
only for 10 seconds so as soon as you
rock back the um Navigator is going to
tell you going to 35 in 10 nine 8 7 six
that's faster than it would be going to
30 now or 35 now so you'll just kind of
count that down and then your uh your NE
your driver knows that you're turning
right you're going to
35 and um then next instruction let your
driver know right away now we're looking
for a speed limit 35 sign and we're
going to go down to 30 mil an
hour and you just finish that
instruction continue on to the next one
um you're going to stop are you gonna
stay about splitting the
sign Steve want don't you tell them how
to split a sign this is for drivers um
one of the things that the the race is
calculated as though you can start and
stop immediately obviously you can't so
if you can envision in your mind that
sign on the side of the road you're
going to start slowing down before you
get to that sign and get to your next
speed on the other side or speeding up
depending on which one it is this is
where the driver needs to know how
quickly his car will either slow down or
speed up uh it's a it's a rule of thumb
thing that the driver just gets used to
uh as basically as long as you make that
correction somewhere around that sign
you're going to be pretty close the the
technique for splitting the sign exactly
comes with experience but you're you're
not going to be far off as long as you
make that speed change somewhere around
where that sign is so think of it as a
linear deceleration you're at 35 you're
going to 30 so the sign will be right in
the middle so you're Crossing it and
continuing before you go down to that
next speed make sense just nod your
heads and go yes okay um so again same
same thing at a stop sign in the next um
instruction and then what we see is a
stop light a blinker I don't see a stop
sign there however the instructions tell
you zero and a 15c pause so what that's
telling you is treat that blinker as if
it were a stop
sign and then go through your regular
stop sign maneuver okay let's go on to
the next page
and um then what I do U in marking my
root
instructions carry over the speed from
the previous page so because it says 30
miles an hour right there but you won't
know once you turn that page what speed
you should actually be driving at and so
you can see down at the bottom of the
previous page you were at 35 so one of
the first things that I'll do when I
mark my instructions is I'm going to
carry over that number at the bottom of
the page to the top of the next page on
every
page
okay so you can see basically um a lot
of the same same things it's just it's
one instruction after another don't
finish any uh don't go on the next
instruction until you completely finish
the instruction from the previous
instruction now here the second one
you've got that little side road sign
and there is a speed change and so it's
a combination instruction here you've
got uh a a sign and then you've got a
right turn and you've got a speed change
from 30 down to 20 you are going to
actually go down to 20 at that sign and
then you're going to make your right
turn at 20 miles an hour so in to 20 out
of 20 or done to 15 out of 20 depending
on the car
right okay um there's there's a there's
a few questions that are that are coming
up in the chat and we'll we'll have a
question and answer time at the end and
so we'll we'll kind of talk about those
if you're carrying tents of second as a
rookie I'm really
impressed we're worried about minutes
not t a seconds well it's a good
question and there is a way to do it but
yeah all right so again you've got a
you've got a sequence of of
um turns and it stops all it stop signs
so all very controlled and then you see
something in the right column that says
look sharp that tells you that that um
Hearn Road is probably not easy to see
the the um you can see the words are to
the right so that means the sign is on
the right if the words are on the left
the sign is on the left so Hearn Road
that it will probably hard to see so
look sharp and then you're going to make
your speed change you've got another
couple of stops so all all very very
simple so uh continuing on to the next
one all right so speed limit
20 oh there we go um again just a speed
change oh now we've got an empty box
here so that does not mean that you can
just drive whatever speed you want to
when you get to that left jog sign that
just means that there will be a left jog
sign but you're going to continue at 20
miles an hour at that side and that is
probably um just to let you know that uh
you notice the next instruction says
come quick look very sharp so once you
see that left jog sign you're going to
be looking right away for that that
right turn and you're not going to be
able to see the sign because it's in
parentheses that tells you you're not
going to be able to see it until maybe
after you make the
turn Okay so assuming you've made that
perfectly you your outspeed is 25 miles
an hour you've lost a second on your
turn apparently this one so you're going
to need to make that up we'll talk about
that later um and then you've got your
stop sign another comes very quick after
that stop you're kind of going onto a
left curve and there will be a Spur off
to the right so you've got a little bit
of a clue as to what the road is going
to look like and at what angle that that
road is going to be that you're going to
turn on so
um
now uh
speed limit 25 making a right turn to
stop sign he wrote down comes quick here
there's a reason for that because if you
turn to the next slide you will see that
that the instructions in the
Box uh go go on to the next
slide sorry comes quick so you've got
you've got a speed change and you're GNA
need to run your your um
stopwatch um wait wait we're too far
back up one
slide here was the comes quick okay oh
no this is Page sorry yeah yeah okay so
that comes quick came came quickly after
the previous instruction so you know to
turn the page quickly so that you're
looking for that right curve sign and
again there was um you see that he's
he's drawn in um the number 20 that was
the speed you were driving four so what
that's telling you this is a delayed
speed change once you cross that right
curve sign you're going to hold 20 miles
an hour for 1 minute and 30 is that 36 1
minute 36 seconds or 1 minute 30
seconds um so you hold it and then you
will increase up to um 30 miles an
hour so um that doesn't happen very
often but if if you see that there's a
speed missing you just write in the
previous speed that you were
driving um and again um you're you need
to complete that instruction so you hold
that 20 for that that whole minute 30
whatever it is and um you're not going
to be looking for anything else except
letting that time elapse before you move
up to 30 miles an hour then that's the
end of the instruction you move on to
the next one which is uh you've got a
couple of stop signs again you've got a
uh a right uh side road sign um that
you're going to be
uh decreasing your speed and then you're
going to be making the turn at that uh
at that
intersection you've got another um at
the the right jog sign it's uh a double
speed change so you're changing at the
sign this is on the next instruction at
25 you're going to hold 25 for a minute
and 12 seconds and then increase to 30
miles an
hour um and then you've got a stop
you've got a hard left uh intersection
and and it tells you okay you've got
you've got something the right side says
possible construction zone um so be
watching for that and then in the next
one you can see that there is kind of an
X intersection sign that you will see
before you make that hard left on River
Road and again we've got a comes quii so
look on the next page and you'll see
another comes quick and that is the end
of the road
work um and you're not doing anything
there you're just maintaining that speed
but just note that you have to pass that
sign before you will make that right
turn on Dem March Road so everything is
sequential you have to finish an
instruction before you go on to the next
one and then we've got a stop we've got
another stop um we've got a look sharp
here on the right first paved Road John
Street you're going to maintain that 20
miles an hour that you had
before um you've got to stop you got to
speed change it a speed limit sign
nothing hard here this is just one
instruction after another just follow it
in sequence check them off after you've
um completed it so that you know which
one you're on you know sometimes you'll
look down and there there might be two
stop signs right in a row it's like oh
my gosh which one am I on make sure that
you mark it off check it off you know
some people just squiggle through the
whole whole thing I like to save mine
and so I like them to look pretty um all
right so let's go on to the next slide
and so what we have uh again just same
turns and stops and then you see that
stop ahead sign um with the top half of
The Hourglass the the sand is in the top
half of The Hourglass this is critical
this is called the beginning of a
Transit and that means that you're not
off the clock but you're temporarily on
pause
so at that point there's not going to be
anybody out there again with a red flag
or anything like that you've got to grab
your stopwatch you got to hit your
stopwatch and you've got to write down
the actual time of day whether you're
doing it from your stopwatch um digital
readout whether you're doing it from
your time of day clock right down the
exact time of day to the second that you
cross that stop ahead sign and you're
going to take that number that time of
day and you're going to add that 30
minutes to it that's in the column to
the left of it and you're going to carry
that over to and it says instruction
number 70 so we're gonna kind of flip to
the next page real quick and then come
back
in so you can see at the third
instruction down next to the arrow
that's going to be your restart time so
you took that previous time plus 30
minutes that is your start time at that
uh at that restarts so this is just
taking you off the clock so you can have
a little bit of a bathroom
break and um then it will uh so it tells
you at that intersection with us 202 um
there will be a Gulf gas station
somewhere around there that tells you at
that intersection you're 10 minutes away
from where the start is and so um and it
also told you under The Hourglass how
many miles that you're going to be
traversing so you're going 10 miles
within 30 minutes not that you have an
odometer no but just to give you a sense
it's like okay I know I've got 30
minutes but how long does it take me to
go to the bathroom and how far are we
from where we are at the start this is
letting you know you know don't dottle
you know don't don't drive 20 miles an
hour um get from point A to point B
quickly and that will give you more time
at your restart can I throw some uh yes
driver things in here quickly we have 13
minutes okay for drivers
when you have a stop sign that's the
easiest thing for you to do and keep in
mind that you're going your next
instruction is stop turn left the tricky
bit is where do you stop uh you've been
practicing your decelerations and what I
find is sometimes intersections are such
that if there's full of gravel which is
common you might slide ways into that
intersection uh or you might stop too
soon and you can't see down the road to
watch the traffic that's coming up to
you uh as rookies you're just going to
creep ahead a little bit so you can make
sure you have a good Clear Vision as to
what's coming down um don't feel that
you have to stay where you stopped if
it's a safety issue uh number two how do
you find roads uh we're going to be in
the Northeast and I'm guessing there's
going to be some trees around there and
sometimes it's hard to see where the
roads are that can happen out in open
field to
I look for things like if there's power
lines going off to the left or the right
there's a chance that there might be a
road right along those power lines um if
you if you can see um markers on the
side of the road sometimes they will
delineate where an intersection be
sometimes you're coming up on a hill and
you can't see that there's a road there
is what I'm saying most of the time you
can and it's really easy but there are a
couple of techniques that you can learn
for judging where a road might be that
you can't see when you're time for you
to start slowing down okay so we
finished our Transit so going I
just out the second light
here okay so this is telling you that
that um turning left onto US
202 uh after you've made the the right
Turner to stop on on 111 there will be
another stop light before you make that
turn on to us
202 okay so now we're back at um we've
gone around traffic circle could I just
ask one question about your
um uh the coming in and the clocking
your time on
um note number 65 and then at that point
you're then off the off the clock for 30
minutes yes I understand that and I
understand that you're counting down and
the bracket numbers counting down to the
starting point again but you did say
that it was 10 miles where did you pick
up pick up the 10 miles from it was
written down under the um hourglass the
first that's just
letting yeah you you you don't have an
odometer so you can't track that that's
just to give you a sense in your head
those those numbers underneath that
first hourglass are telling you how far
it is to the next one yeah it looks like
an odometer reading yeah no got it
that's perfect answered perfect thank
you all right on to the next page then
uh you've got a sequence of arrows um
we've got a right arrow then a left
Arrow then a left Arrow then a left
Arrow you're probably going to be
circling back on yourself so um but
before you make that restart double and
triple check your time and look for the
cars around you again pull out your
order of start make sure that the other
cars are there all right next
page next page
there we go so a right turn a right turn
this is probably a maze and so you will
probably see other cars that are coming
towards you they might be coming from a
side road they might be coming right at
you and they might be at the same
intersection as you and you're supposed
to turn right and they're turning left
don't let that bother you this is
designed it's very cute how he does that
um don't lose focus run your race follow
your instructions do the maneuver cross
it off do the next maneuver cross it off
do the next maneuver cross it off and
don't be distracted by anything else
you're seeing out there um now you see
that that uh camera video camera with a
circle around it with a slash that means
that at that point there will not be a
checkpoint for a while and that's
probably because there is
something that could cause you to lose
time and and you know just kind of get a
little bit off so um you can see that
there's a signal there you may have a
green signal you may have a red signal
and you're going straight so you could
you could lose seconds or you could be
early and need to fix that too but that
lets you know that at least you'll have
time to correct that after that uh after
that camera uh comes back without the
circle and the
slash um and you will have time to make
up any loss that you have and uh again
you've got a a blinker being treated as
a stop sign and let's continue on to the
next next
page and this is my favorite instruction
of the day is that clock with a slash
through it that tells you you are off
the clock it's the driver's favorite one
too but if you see that coming up you
know you're probably going to see a
checkpoint crew somewhere in those last
three instructions so just be aware make
sure that you're on time you've made
whatever Corrections you need to so that
you're ready to just wave at that
checkpoint and
go okay and then there's some
information boxes so don't don't zone
out once you're off the clock because
now there's some really important things
you're going to need to do you may need
to stop for gas because and that first
box is going to tell you what's going to
happen that evening it'll tell you about
the host dinner it'll tell you about any
activities tell you how long you need to
stay at the park for May and it will
also tell you about parking information
at the
hotels okay and then the next
slide will tell you about and then you
then that will take you into the Finish
gate where you get a little sticker from
um Rachel Classen and um then they'll
give you your scores and um you'll be
given your start order for the next day
so you'll know how to do your
calculations and know when to get up and
when to get breakfast and all that good
stuff and it'll tell you where you're
going to be picking up your root
instructions and it would also tell you
that your first refueling stop will be
in 135 miles so make sure you've got at
least a half a tank of gas and it'll
also tell you if you have a toll
generally tolls at this point are all
electronic um sometimes it they actually
do it the oldfashioned way with cash but
you'll be off the clock when you do when
there's a toll so um just be prepared if
you need to have cash for the tolls then
then you you can get that and they'll
tell you if you do and how much it is
yeah all right so that is our root
instructions and uh let's talk about a
couple of special situations real quick
and I know we're going to run over and I
apologize for that because I want to
allow time for question and answer but
um time allowances go
ahead
um the race doesn't want you to do
stupid things and I think that's fairly
obvious um when you have a situation
that's beyond your control um you
there's the road is obstructed because a
train broke in front of you and blocks
the intersection and you have no way of
knowing how to get around it or where to
go and you're just stuck there uh which
has happened recently uh the race crew
will come by and give you in
instructions if you're running to a
train out in the field and you have to
wait a couple of minutes for it you
calculate how much time generally as a
driver what you're looking for is the
ability to pull over and stop get out of
the traffic because once that train goes
whatever cars are in front of you are
not going to be able to go the speed
that you want to go so you're just got
to pull over and wait Navigator will be
running the watch when you can go safely
and to your speed pull out the Navigator
will figure out how to figure out the uh
the 10c increments that's required for
filling out a time allowance may have
you speed up may have you slow down so
that you can hit it right at that 10
seconds and turn in the time delay to
the next checkpoint official that's
looking for it or asking for it that
will be either at the lunch stop or at
the end of the day and there's there uh
two time allowance sheet sheets that are
stapled to the back of your root
instructions so you just pull one off
fill it out tell them what happened and
you're not going to be responsible for
making up a five minute delay if um if
it was beyond your control beyond your
control this is the trick if you have a
flat tire or you run out of gas or the
car breaks and you get it back running
again those are not accepted as time
delays or if you missed a turn and go
five miles down the road and come back
not that we've ever done that you know
or had a flat or had the engine
breakdown you know we've gone through
all those things but you can't you know
you can't have a car problem or your
mistake it does not count for a Time
allowance anything legit where the road
is blocked and you can't go you can do a
Time allowance on that okay next slide
making up
time when you can uh because you will
have you'll need to make up time for
turns you'll need to make up time
um for whatever circumstances it is um
determine how many seconds you're late
and generally the best way to correct
that is using the 10% rule if you are 5
Seconds late um you were just going to
go to a speed that's 10% faster than the
assigned speed so you're you're SP
you're on a a 30 m hour road and you've
lost 5 Seconds you're going to go 33 for
50 seconds so 10 times the number of
seconds you were late at 10% over what
happens if you're right in the middle of
that 50 seconds and there was a right
curve sign and you had to change to
another speed just change to 10% over
that new speed and continue um
calculating your seconds and then once
you're done you go back to the assigned
speed and you're on time and this also
works when you're when you need to lose
time um it's it's rare but sometimes you
have to leave early if there's going to
be cross traffic or you have to speed up
to pass a slow vehicle um you go 10%
over to pass that slow vehicle and then
you go 10% slower to make the correction
so um use all the information available
at your disposal and that may involve
hacking off of other parts and we'll
tell you how to do that another time
maybe over a beer um uh next
slide when you're
lost um sometimes you just blow it and
you miss a turn or an instruction um if
you're driving at a Ste speed that
doesn't correspond to the road um then
you may be wrong if you see a stop sign
and there's not one on your course
instructions you may be wrong if you're
on a long straight road and can't see
the car in front of or behind you you
may be wrong
so here's the deal drivers you're the
one that's watching where you are in the
race um if suddenly you're getting the
the feeling like damn I'm driving too
fast for this road or I'm driving too
slow for this road or um you uh there
are nobody nobody's on the side of the
road watching the race go by and you're
not sure you just don't think it's right
don't keep going easiest way to check
that it's just pull over and stop where
it's safe you know there's another race
car one minute behind you if that car
doesn't show up and the next car doesn't
show up you're off course and this is
when your Navigator is going to hit the
stopwatch as you turn around and go back
to the and try to figure out the
Maneuvers the Dr the turns that you've
made to get to where you are to get back
to the race course if you think you're
on the race course again you can wait
another car comes by one minute okay now
you know where the course is where you
went wrong and how late you are because
you have your order of start and you
know that that car is 10 minutes behind
you uh so you're 10 minutes late you
know what do you do okay so you're back
on your course um 10 minutes is hard to
make up especially if the speeds are
fast if you're supposed to be doing 45
or 50 you're not going to make it uh so
just write it off and get to where
you're in the middle between two cars
that are one minute apart uh put
yourself 30 seconds behind a car that
you know is on the course and doing okay
and then when you get to the the
checkpoint you're just G to lose that
that leg okay you toss that one out you
got plenty to toss out so that's a
that's a gimme and then you start the
next
leg 30 seconds behind the car that's a
minute in front of you now you're on a
regular leg this is your position now
because the checkpoint will will Mark
you at that point and if you stay on
time and stay on course 30 seconds
behind the car that's in front of you
you'll have a good
leg so the trick is throw away the bad
leg and don't mess the next leg which
can really help okay and we are at time
but I want to allow for questions I
apologize that we're running a little
bit late but we tend to do that because
we talk a lot so um any questions that
we haven't answered from the chat J yes
this Jeff uh and and this is actually
for Ken Ken can you is there a way to uh
gather all the questions so if we don't
answer somebody's questions I can uh
answer them uh in an email this week yes
when you when you quit Zoom if if the
questions were in chat there'll be a
little thing pop up I'll also save it
and I'll get that to you and it's a
dialogue just like it is
there we don't get your questions
answered we'll answer them this week
another thing is my email is jeffg
greatrace.com if we don't answer your
question tonight somehow we miss it just
email me or Houston at Houston
greatrace.com and we'll answer those
questions I'll get
everybody yeah my email we're gonna be
in Michigan and if you have questions
there we're going to have a a little
seminar in Michigan we'll be happy to
talk to you in person we will have a
seminar again at the start of the big
race so you'll be able to see us in
person and ask questions and those
places too I just I want to thank the
veterans that were answering some of
these questions along the way and
sharing some of your expertise that is
that's what this is this is a family we
are here to help you we are here to
answer your questions to to help you to
succeed uh and just enjoy the race as
much as we do I will get the the clock
and speedometer information and send
that out in this week's newsletter if
you're not getting the we we ly
newsletter every Thursday comes out at
different times of the day 2 or 3 in the
afternoon sometimes it's 5: in the
afternoon eastern time if you're not
getting that every Wednesday send me an
email at jeffg greatrace.com so that we
can find out why you're not getting that
uh
email um this video will be available
afterwards uh several people have ask
about that um I I want to thank and
point out to all the veterans I've
noticed on this call Peter hery who I
already mentioned Hank Maul has done a
great job answering questions uh Bob
meric is on this on this uh video my
buddy Ken Spencer my Pebble Beach buddy
is handling the all the uh uh ins and
outs of this uh this whole deal I really
appreciate that my buddy from Maine
Harvey Litman uh Sam mavi's on this and
Sam is filming this great race uh for
uh several episodes of Sam's Garage on
television cool uh Sam's on this U Susan
Norse and Peter Brown uh are on this
cail our our host they're we're going to
their Hometown in Free Port main this
year Scott Tams coming back finally
after many years glad to see you back
buddy and last but not least Wes
Thompson can't wait to see you in
Michigan andon on the great race uh uh
and thank you hey Jeff I have I have a
quick question I'm I'm looking kind of
through the questions and shanana who is
a fabulous expert Navigator has a really
good question and I want to um bring
that up question about instructions
regarding position of a building rather
than a sign as a marker before turn
sometimes you'll see a building shown in
the root instruction itself and there
may be a a change of speed do you change
speed at the building or is it just in
the instructions as a
reference just in instructions as a
reference okay it's so if there's a sign
then you will change speed at the sign
but if there is a building that's just
so that you know you're in the right
place generally the building is on the
corner so it's a kind of a m it it'll be
like you know Arco station or something
like that yep I also want to thank you
Steve and Janet you are perfect for this
thank you this is not the end keep going
I just wanted to get those in before
people started dropping off okay
and I want to point this out I I I ran
across this and some of you may know who
Pat Summit is she was the women's
basketball coach at University of
Tennessee for many years one of the best
and she has a lot of really great quotes
and and I love this one winning is fun
sure but winning is not the point
wanting to win is the point not giving
up is the point never letting up is the
point never being satisfied with what
you've done
is the point to finish is to
win and that's what we'd like to leave
you with
tonight all right so thank you all and
we will see you either in Owensboro or
we will see you in uh in Michigan so
thank you all for being with us tonight
and uh good luck to everybody